[Music]
my name is Eric and again ski I am
professor of architectural history at
the Graduate School of Design and the
director of the ph.d program in
architecture landscape architecture and
urbanism
today we're going to be talking about
the relationship of a book that was
published in 1949 by Rudolph it cover
entitled architectural principles in the
age of humanism and its characterization
of the Renaissance architect as we'll
see this is a book that had an
extraordinary impact on two distinct
groups the first was the Renaissance
architectural historian this book
offered a new approach to the way we
understand the architecture of the 15th
and the 16th century in Italy the other
group was the modernist architect it is
strange to think that a book on the
Renaissance might have an impact on
modernist thinking but this book
revolutionized our understanding of
geometry modular pattern and the ways in
which diagrams can be used to explain
the work of the architect two things to
say about this book the first is that it
was highly invested in an abstract and
intellectual approach to the Renaissance
it underscored the rise of theory in the
15th and the 16th century and the ways
in which the works of a given architect
might offer a coherent kind of
investigation into a set of problems
surrounding perspective proportion
geometry and the advent of ideal form in
architecture this highly abstract
approach had repercussions what it means
ironically is that vid cover was
absolutely disinvested from the
complexities of history he was not
interested in the cultural context out
of which architecture arose he does not
delve into patronage religious history
the monastic orders particular events
that might have marked the Renaissance
instead he steps back to analyze
architectural form as an autonomous
project at the heart of this approach is
the notion of the
eridan the word paradigm comes from the
Greek it means both pattern and to show
side-by-side in the latter definition we
really get a sense of a comparative
approach that to put two things together
means essentially the creation of a
synthesis so the word ultimately serves
to underscore the creation of an
outstanding example of something of a
model a standard an epitome an ideal a
Paragon the assumption on recovers part
is that Renaissance architects were
after such paradigms that they sought
and developed them and ultimately
through that process we're after the
core principles of architectural form by
the same token what's also true is that
Vic overs vid covers very own approach
became paradigmatic in other words it
offered a standard means of approaching
the historical past of interpreting the
past and even of generating form itself
how do we understand this book is it an
interpretation of Renaissance
architecture is it a template for
modernist architectural thinking what we
can say is that vid covers is a broad
attempt to characterize the theory of
architecture as it emerged in the
fifteenth and sixteenth century in a
distinct set of places in Florence and
Rome and in Venice furthermore the book
is broken up into four chapters that
deal with issues that Vic overtook to be
absolutely fundamental first there is
the question of symbolism in other words
how buildings mean the second chapter
looks at the problem of the
appropriation of form in other words how
did architects look back to the deep
past and in particular to the pagan
classical past sees that tradition
reinterpret in syntax and
invent classicism as a system third the
question of typology and the development
of building types are we talking about
churches are we talking about villas are
we talking about institutional buildings
and lastly the question of proportion
the geometric ideal the question of
measure and while any number of
architects and buildings texts are vocht
in his book it's also clear that there
are essentially two key players in his
narrative the first we'll talk about
today is Albert II a theorist and an
architect a real renaissance man he was
also a painter and second a Venetian
architect from the 16th century named
Andrea Palladio these two figures
essentially represent the whole of the
Italian Renaissance for Vic cover and
when we think about that we understand
that Vic covers approach was essentially
reductive what might we expect the
historian to garner from a picture of
the Renaissance architect or the
buildings that he erected we might
assume that the historian would be after
a history of patronage for example a
history of the politics that gave rise
to a particular commission who would
consider the great events that marked
the 15th and 16th century changes in
military technology also the question of
politics or religion during this period
the influence of the papacy the rise of
dookle States and their sense of an
autonomy from the papacy all of these
are left out of fit covers narrative to
read vid cover is to see a process of
mental abstraction at work in other
words what vid cover was after wasn't
the discrete cultural meaning of a
particular building in a particular
context he's not after giving us some
real and robust
of the 16th century worldview instead he
wants to bring together the classical
kit of parts that make a building
formalize itself that allow it to
transform into the buildings we still
have today
in other words vid cover is looking for
a kind of deep structure we might call
it that organizes an architectural form
he's going after the identification of
their component parts what is a portico
what is a column this is why ultimately
he relies on diagrams to explain
architecture he looks through the
complex appearance of a building like
this and all its three dimensionality
and distills it into its most basic
elements through plan sometimes
elevation in other words he develops a
syntax a language of form he's
interested in Renaissance architecture
as an explicitly and these are his words
as an explicitly mathematical science
which worked with spatial units fit
covers whole analysis along these lines
can be understood as a philosophical
exercise not an historical analysis in
which thinking and reason emerge as the
defining characteristics of the
architect and this is what's
demonstrated through the diagrams
ultimately what emerges from this is the
autonomy of architecture itself and we
see this when we look at what his
diagram of the villa Cornero does you
can see that he's interested only in the
plan he cuts away the rear monumental
staircase he minimizes and essentially
elides the entrance porch takes away the
column and therefore anything that might
signify a supportive function he takes
away the side wings he takes away the
poche the scale everything in other
words that Palladio indicates in his
plan and elevation we want to think
about how these diagrams give us a
certain highly particular view of the
Renaissance which privileges geometry
all the way from its basic spatial units
to the general order given to the
universe by God